etet des 10 lieux culturels aus.
D David McMillan, merci de nous
acaccueillir. On a l'impression
quque vous êtes s comme sorti de
prprison, dans votre esprit.
DADAVID McMILLAN,
chchef et restaurateur
- - Non, il n'y a pas de prison.
C'C'est juste... C'est le temps
d'd'accrocher ses patins, de plr
soson tablier et de passer à a e
chchose.
- - Y as-tu des éléments qui ont
pepesé plus que d'autres?
LaLa pandémie, est-ce que
c'c'est un facteur?
- - C'est sûr! L La pandémie ...
L'L'après s pandémie était piree
lala pandémie. Ce qu'on disait :
ThThe labor shorted; le manque
d'd'employés après s la pandémi,
c'c'était...
cocomme un coup de grâcece
paparce qu'on avait une légère..
"A"Ah, cool! La pandémie est
fifinie, on est tous vaccinés,
totout va redevenir normal."
- - Ça va reprendre!
- - Puis non! C'est pire qu'à
lala pandémie parce que au moins
pendndant la pandémie, on était
ququelques employés, on arrivait
àà t travailler et faire l'affa.
MaMais ouvrir un restaurant
sasans plongeurs, sans serveurs.
QuQuand il manque trois cuisinis
popour faire des chiffres,
pupuis on a finalement le droit
dede faire des chiffres.
MaMais on ne peut pas faire
dedes chiffres parce qu'il n'y a
pepersonne. Puis, il y a ça
auaussi : The brain trust;
l'l'élément intellectuel de
cecette brigade au restaurant
ququi est là d depuis des annéee
totout à cououp, on ne sait plùu
pepersonne est! C'est... c'est..
OnOn ne construit pas un grand
rerestaurant une semaine!
- - Et comment on règle e ça?
IlIl y a eu, il y a deux semain,
lala controverse du salaire
miminimum chez Picard.
IlIl y a eu... comment on règlee
çaça d'après s vous?
- - Ça va êtrtre pour quelqu'un
d'd'autre à régégler. Je pense e
jeje me suis battu et plaint.
EtEt j'ai travaillé à c coeur pn
cocomme un ambassadeur de
lala cuisine pour Montréal.
J'J'ai une très s belle carrièr,
jeje suis... content d'êtrtre
cacapable de finir ma carrièrere
enen santé quoique ce soit
àà 50 0 ans. Mais il reste
dedes s batailles à.....
àà  être fafaites,
- - Comme?
- - ... mais ce n'est pas
leles miennes.
- - Non, je comprends. Mais
dodonnnnez-nous une idée de comt
onon peut régler ça parce que ts
leles restaurateurs parlent de e
prproblèmeme d'aller chercher la
mamain-d'oeuvre. Est-ce que c'et
enen payant mieux les gens? Este
quque c'est en revoyant le modè?
- - Oui, on peut payer mieux
leles gens. Il n'y a pas de
prproblèmeme à payayer mieux le;
mamais il faut que les clients
sosoient avertis qu'on... Tu sa,
ququand j'ai commencé à c cuisi,
ilil y a plusieurs années, on
cacapotait quand on servait
dedes plats principaux à 2 22 $à
2525 $. Puis là, , dans mes anns
3030, on a franchi le 35, 40 $
popour le plat principal.
AuAujourd'hui, on regarde,
onon s'en va dans les steaks
àà 12525 $, les spaghettis au
hohomard à 12020 $... les foiess
àà 7 75 $. Tu sais, ça va finiù?
OnOn y va, on n'y arrive. Mais n
momoment donné, le client, il a
pepeur de faire quoi? Dans ces
rerestaurant haut de gamme qui
prpromeuvent le tourisme à
MoMontréal, peut-être e un tax
brbreak. Peut-êtrtre de... il ya
bebeaucoup de ces restaurants.
OnOn pourrait quasiment faire ue
apapplication pour... comment on
didit? Canada countries grant.
IlIl y a un restaurant, mais aps
çaça, il y a un restaurant
d'd'envergure théâtralale,
d'd'envergure artistique,
d'd'envergure... On ne fait pas
jujuste le strict minimum de
seservir aux gens à mananger.
OnOn fait beaucoup plus.
C'C'est une taxe ou peut-êtree
unun bénéfice de la culture.
MaMartin Picard a peut-êtrtre eu
drdroit d'êtrtre... il y a même
bebeaucoup de gens à l'e'extérir
dudu Québec et à l'i'intérieur
dudu Québec.
- - Donc, imaginer des manièrers
d'd'aider des institutions,
dedes endroits qui sont devenus
dedes piliers de la restauration
àà M Montréal.
- - Peut-être!e! Tu sais,
auaujourd'hui, on paye pour
leles cartes de crédit, on paye
popour les POS software,
leles systèmes s de réservation,
UbUber Eats, Doordash, toutes
ceces affaires-là. . Puis, on et
rerendu qu'un restaurant,
pepeut-êtrtre hyper bien géré,
ouoù on compte et on fait des
ininventaires à touous les joura
peut-êtrtre s'en sortir avec 4 ,
3 3 %.
- - Ça, ça étonne les gens qui
sese disent : Joe beef, vous
roroulez sur l'or! Vous, l'arge,
sisi vous l'avez fait dans votre
vivie, c'est parce que vous avez
eueu beaucoup de restaurants :
4,4, 5.
- - Non, je vous dirire. Le joef
fafait un peu de succès.s.
LeLes restaurateurs que vous alz
vovoir, qui prennent des retrais
enen général, qui ont peu de
susuccès,s, sont souvent les
prpropriétaires de leurs murs;
ququi sont propriétés de leurs
imimmeubles, qui ont acheté des
imimmeubles dans des quartiers
ilil y a plusieurs années et ont
oeoeuvré en tant que restaurant
pependant 20 ans et ils peuvent
prprendre une retraite à l'a'aià
lala campagne parce qu'ils ont
vevendu leurs murs.
- - Comme vous!
- - Mais souvent, on voit des
rerestaurants qui arrivent, qui
onont travaillé pendant 15 ans,
pupuis que, la propriétaire de
l'l'immeuble double le loyer.
OnOn a commencé à p payer 5000 $
dede loyer. 15 ans plus tard,
c'c'est rendu 20 000 $ de loyer,
pupuis éventuellement,
çaça ne marche plus.
- - Donc, contrairement à
cece qu'on pourrait croire,
dedes Joe Beef où on ne peut pas
avavoir de table... Je pense...
CoCombien de temps pour avoir
unune table maintenant? Un an
ouou...?
- - Bon, maintenant, c'est norm.
AvAvant la pandémie, c'est sûr e
leles réservations ouvraient dex
momois à l'a'avance. On était ps
cece jour-là..
- - Mais l'argent ne rentre pasà
plpleine porte?
- - Non, non! Ça prend
14140 employés pour faire
2020 000 $ de vente. On est 20.
C'C'est beaucoupup de personnel.
C'C'est un group hero. C'est un
fofood cost énorme. Mais surtout
ququand on pratique les protéins
dede qualité, du boeuf de quali.
OnOn vend du homard,
dede la pétoncle, le flétan...
c'c'est une fortune! Puis,
ilil ne faut pas oublier
ququ'on paye le même p prix
quque les Américains. Et souven,
leles poissons du Québec
etet les poissons des Maritimes,
leles pêchcheurs préfèrerent vee
auaux États-Unis, parce que...
USUS dollars dans leur compte
dede banque. Vous voyez ce que
jeje veux dire? Un flétan qui et
3535 $ à M Montréal, des fois,
esest 45 $ à N New York, US dol.
LeLe mêmeme flétan du même b ba.
YoYou know?
- - Pourquoi c'est devenu
dedes adresses si reconnues?
BoBon, on pense évidemment
àà l'i'image de Barack Obama
etet de M. Trudeau dans votre
rerestaurant. Qu'est-ce que
vovous avez eu comme recette,
cocomme baguette magique qui a
fafait que c'est devenu des liex
imimportants pour Montréal?
- - C'est comme la tempêtete
paparfaite. Frédéric Morin est
unun grand cuisinier, mon assoc,
ququi demeure en place au
rerestaurant, qui est encore
momotivé, qui veut encore
trtravailler. Frédéric est
unun grand cuisinier qui avait
unun bon cheminement. J'avais
unun bon cheminement pareil.
OnOn s'est retrouvés à c ce mom-
llà. . Il n'y avait pas beaucoup
dede restaurants, des petits
rerestaurants chefs propriétair,
cece n'était pas quelque chose i
exexistait il y a 16 ans, 17 an.
FaFait que... Peut-être,e, Frédc
etet moi, à c ce moment-là,,
onon était peut-êtrtre surqualis
popour avoir un restaurant
dede 25 places. Pour nous,
fafaire 25 clients, il y a 16 a,
chchez Joe Beef, avec nos
exexpériences et notre savoir-
fafaire de la cuisine française,
c'c'était facile pour nous.
OnOn anéantissait les clients
unun par un tant qu'ils rentrait
dadans la porte! On faisait
2525 clients, puis on était
fafacilement capables de garantr
ququ'on allait complètemement
leles éclater. Puis, on a fait a
pependant plusieurs années,
jujusqu'à t temps que les Améris
s's'en rendent compte, jusqu'à
tetemps qu'on s'est fait offrir
unun livre, d'écrire un livre
d'd'une maison de publication
amaméricaine, puis à c ce momen,
c'c'est sûr ququ'on a commencé
àà a avoir des articles en Asie.
OnOn s'est ramassés sur la liste
dedes 100 meilleurs restaurants,
jeje pense, en 95 ou 96.
PuPuis là, , c'était... on était
unun restaurant de 40 places
ququi étaient plein.
- - Question que je voulais
vovous demander : M. Trudeau,
M.M. Obama, ils ont payé?
- - Cher! Oui.
- - Ils ont payé l'addition?
- - Oui.
- - Ils ne sont pas partis...
- - Non! En plus, la facture
ététait salée, parce qu'il
a a fallu bloquer des tables,
ilil a fallu mettre personne
auau bar, il a fallu nourrir
lele Secret Service et tout.
MaMais, je me suis rendu compte,
apaprès lala pandémie, que j j's
5050 ans, et aussi, comme un gee
dede farce, comme une joke que e
didis depuis des années en cuise
: : j'ai tout le temps parlé
d'd'arrêter r à 5 50 ans.
JeJe pensais pas que j'allais
lele faire, mais je le fais.
C'C'était soit ça... que j'arrêe
llà o ou je continue pendant
1010 ans.
- - Parce que le climat
enen cuisine, vous racontez
dadans un article; vous êtes s é
enen France et là, çaça gueulait
ououah, ouah, ouah! Vous êtess
ararrivé dans l'Ouest américain
pupuis c'était doux,
c'c'était plus smooth. On est
cocomment ici? Est-ce qu'on peut
êêtrtre calme, est-ce qu'on peut
êêtrtre équilibré?
- - Bien, il y a un sens de
l'l'urgence en restauration, OK?
IlIl y a peut-être e 120 persons
ququi viennent manger à 7 7 h,
ilil y a 10 entrées, 10 plats
prprincipaux à c choisir avec
totous les petits détatails, OK,
mamaisis aussi, il faut se souvr
ququ'on une permission spéciale.
OnOn ne prend pas à la a légèree
lala permission d'un êtrtre humn
dede nous laisser introduire
plplusieurs éléments :
prprotéines, carbohydrate
ouou légumes à l l'intérieur
dede leur corps. Il y a
unune certaine rigueur de
lala restauration professionnele
dede me donner la permission
cece soir de me laisser introdue
dedes huîtreses, du saumon cru,
dudu foie gras, des asperges,
dudu caviar, de la volaille,
dudu lapin mi-cuit à l'i'intérir
dede votre corps. C'est une
reresponsabilité qu'un cuisinier
nene peut pas prendre à l la lé.
IlIl y a une rigueur
prprofessionnelle en cuisine hae
gagamme qui s'apprend,
mamalheureusement, d'une façon,
jeje ne veux pas dire agreressi,
mamais... c'est important que
lele travail soit hygiénique,
bibien fait et que la rigueur
sosoit comprise par tout le mone
etet même qu'u'il y ait un certn
clclimat de peur parce que c'est
imimportant que tout le monde
dadans la cuisine comprenne
ququ'on est en train d'introduie
dedes aliments à l l'intérieur
dedes gens.
- - Le plus gentiment possible
avavec les employés,
mamais vous dites : Il faut
ququ'il y ait une discipline.
- - Je dis pas doucement avec un
ccâlin,n, OK? Je dis : Le jeune,
s's'il te plaît, v veille
tata mise en place, c'est
ininacceptable. Dans le temps,
ilil y a 10 ans, on se faisait
huhurler après.s. Mais on se red
cocompte que...
- - Mais est-ce que les jeunes
acacceptent ça, cette disciplin-
llà?
- - Oui, oui. Parce qu'il y a
unune manière d de le faire.
T'T'sais, moi, quand j'ai commeé
enen restauration, peut-être e e
lala manièrere était plus archï.
CÇa se dit, archaïque?
- - Oui.i. Là, , vous allez allr
susur vos terres, cultiver.
VoVous revenez aux sources
enen amont de ce qu'il y a
dadans la cuisine.
- - On pratique la viticulture
àà Saiaint-Armand dans des vigns
didifférents dans des vinifera
etet des hybrides. On pratique
auaussi... On a des poiriers,
dedes pommiers, des pruniers fat
quque oui, il y a du travail à
fafaire et c'est ça, le travail
esest pareil un peu comme
lala restauration; C'est long et
c'c'est dur.
- - Dans trois ou quatre ans,
vovous allez revenir peut-êtrtr?
UnUn projet de restaurant.
- - Non, non, c'est fini.
- - Non? C'est fini?
OnOn est fiers comme Montréalais
enen tout cas, que vous soyez...
QuQue vous ayez fait
cece que vous avez fait.
- - C'est gentil, merci.
- - NoNon, pour vrai. Merci.
- - C'est moi qui vous remerci